and what do you [ __ ] what do you think
you get from it just that it's fun that
it's exciting to have sex you like to
have sex yeah I do
it doesn't hurt I love to suck dick oh
my foots right all right princess hey
hey welcome back it's been six months or
more since we talked last what's new in
your life anything is anything change
I'm staying with a client I'm actually
just trying to do a lot better for
myself right now are you still using
drugs of course and when you say stay
with a client he that he allows you to
see other clients most the time so you
see sometimes it's like angry jealous oh
yeah and you know what that's all right
it's all right I let him you know but
yeah I still see all the people yeah I
still date normally yeah I'm in charge
yeah I saw the I saw the dynamics of
your relationship with them you're
you're clearly in charge of the
relationship thank you
and so with that with that relationship
we want memo to it was he what does that
relationship like and he would it um
it's actually pretty cool
is it boyfriend/girlfriend type thing or
is it no well sometimes I gotta pretend
like it is because he thinks it is you
know but I mean like I have friends and
they'll they'll call him they'll tell
him Franco's face he's like you're true
you know and he's a little upset
whatever so it's I have to sometimes I
tell him you know this what he wants to
hear you know does he see other ladies
on the side so you well he does he goes
yeah don't get me wrong
yes you're both kind of straying a bit
yeah yeah
and he's generally good to you oh yeah
he's great yeah
so so where does your life stand down
your family knows you're out here yeah
how do and you're you're very open with
them yeah we're about your situation and
what you're doing I actually showed on
the first one what they did yeah
way cool how'd they react to that I
didn't actually they didn't even reply I
guess there's no reply but you know I
want them to know you know right nothing
nothing you're doing you would surprise
them it sounds like no they already know
yeah
they come visit me they told you what
they actually my dad just came and
visited me not long ago were you from
were they from you'd have to say if you
want to say oh they yeah thank you
I'm sorry um it's a long way away yeah
okay is that LA No
got it have you been arrested for did it
for this no you've never been arrested
no well I've never been arrested for
protesting you're one of the flashiest
girls out there I'm surprised it I
believe in karma a lot so I try not to
do anything that will bring anything bad
to me any worse than it what already
happens um so I try to stick to myself
and just not do anything wrong
wrong you know I try not to give her a
reason to stop me
I mean do you do you view what you're
doing for these men is you just I viewed
it as my work but I know but it's it's
also something that is therapeutic
almost for them yeah could we say a
beautiful me - for you - uh-huh
you mean it helps you by the things you
need to buy oh yes definitely yeah yeah
that is our other other therapeutic Oh
things about it yeah there are a few
things about it to be honest which would
be like what you know different people
to talk to
things ago do like presents exciting
things yeah they're nice gifts and
things like that huh I mean yeah when's
the last time you actually had a
boyfriend of your own high school high
school mom and this kind of get this
lifestyle gets in the way of that of
course I yeah I mean well actually hold
up any wine um I wouldn't call my
boyfriend though that's why I didn't say
it for like the last four or five years
of my life I I he he I met him he called
me I had a ad posted online and he and
he called me off online and the first
day he moved me into the mansion it was
a trick but I left the table for the
last four or five years of my life
before I came here
well I came here for him but he put his
hands on me for the first time so I left
so he's like a sugar daddy kind of yeah
sugar daddy good one like
multi-millionaire yeah there's a good
one
are those relationships kind of well
over here after five years of living
with him he put his hands on me for the
first time but he was real [ __ ] up
he wanted me to suck his dick but I
didn't want to because he had been out
for days he and he was seeing another
girl
and he didn't want for the kind of Milan
so i didn't suck his dick and he got
real angry i don't like a martini glass
like this
boom smashes [ __ ] in my leg
tackles me off the bed and starts
kicking me and he's he says he doesn't
know like he blacked out but I ran out
of the hotel over a Hyatt Regency by LAX
I ran out of there with a belly shirt on
bikini bottom on a glass coming out my
legs just go sit down my leg and from
there I know I knew no one here are just
getting here my luggage was there my
phones was there the one person I knew
it was uh
oh and I can take that out all right
thank you I can take it out the one
person I knew was the person I was
buying drugs from so that so you've been
here ever since
yeah and that's how I started walking
the street well yeah and you've been
here how many years I almost you know
and do you see give a plan to get out of
this situation or this life oh i
planning it clean soon thank you you got
you've been clean before yeah I got here
I was clean yeah and the director using
her kind of a sorry yeah that's [ __ ]
me up your [ __ ] wine nervous system
up because you're using them all right
yeah which one is your favorite
heroin crack oh I like it
Oh what are the differences between
heroin crack and crystal meth um heroin
is a downer to opiate you fall asleep
crystal meth or cocaine all three years
okay is what just get here quickly so
math is like under your kitchen sink
cabinet it's all horrible stuff I think
it's supposed to make you horny but it
makes you horny and cocaine that's
correct cocaine crack cocaine rocked up
that's uh sweet up you know keeps you
awake
how often will you use like every day
every day every day did you kind of need
it to do this yeah I needed a real-ass
just just to do this with the guys and
so on
oh yeah I don't want to do it sober no
no I probably could what using deal with
not have you ever considered working
with a pimp yeah I have in the past you
you verse with temps yeah and tell me
the difference in with it without a pimp
ah with it it's a it's fun with one you
know you have to have a good time with
the person you like they look out they
got your back so you never got to worry
about nothing if they're a good one
they're a good one they're how it's been
supposed to be I like to I would prefer
that but if they're a bad one then
they're just pretending pimp it [ __ ]
that what you got no money just think of
that that's I'm saying if the pimp is
taking all your money what's the upside
of that relationship mostly they're just
thinking about themselves they'll go
[ __ ] but you kind of expressed that it
is actually kind of good to be with a
good yeah I think that one is a
going-out pimp supposed to be a real
pimp and [ __ ] yeah
because he treats you really well yeah
if I you ever saying they yeah you got
everything you need and you ain't gotta
manage your money you ain't got to deal
with nothing you just got everything you
need
do whatever you want yeah so I guess
what you're saying it's some some are
great and summer yeah a real pimps good
one yeah some know how to treat their
ladies yeah so know how to do it yeah
that makes sense more so not them that
then there are the ones that deal but
there are ones that do where did you
first get the idea to do this as a line
of work well years ago I never walked
but I would post on Backpage you know I
post on Backpage and you get 200 an hour
you got you get so much for freaky stuff
you know I had this guy paying me 500
bucks oh all I would do is lay down he
come on top of me with his knees he jack
off
and he all he wanted to do was come on
my face and I was like ten minutes and I
got like 500 bucks right it's not bad
Annie wiped it off and clean it for me
with baby wipes out there yep how's it
going one and then you get like maybe
100 to 200 more just the video it so
you've done all kinds of crazy and this
guy I've made like 20 videos really
uh-huh
and what happens with those videos oh
hey just an our phones yeah that's it
sometimes I show on the people yeah I
got a bunch of great pictures I'll bet
you do I do I love big serious don't
don't lose your phone I know I wear as
my hyung he's going home
this is this line of work ever get can
you depress sometimes get down oh yeah
yeah when you think you're pregnant oh
that's a scare
that's just having me feel oh well how
long ago
could you do sometimes without condoms
sometimes yeah sometimes you're not
expecting to but it's just you just
don't pull one on and already like a
good regular you know one that you see
all the time and you know the gun and
sometimes like once in a blue moon you
don't want to I'll be down I'll be down
but that's where I feel I got to know
you very [ __ ] well and and even that
I don't even want I pull the kind of mom
I got the kind of on the bed but they
just do it without it and [ __ ] I can't
do nothing about it
you ever had diseases around like that
uh yeah yeah easy ones that you just
going back there get medicine they go
away what's what's the worst thing about
doing this is it is a career Pauly's
I've been arrested for a bunch of stuff
and been in a bunch of trouble and it's
the worst place in the world I've never
been arrested here that's right you said
you never arrested for prostitution
right
no never for prostitution but other
stuff yeah drugs DUI stuff like that
yeah and do you think you would you just
do you enjoy what you're doing kind of
art I know - I'm not gonna lie yeah
should I lie no no okay the truth it's
like okay yeah you enjoy it I do uh do
you think you gain the self esteem from
from it and the way the guys know I
already have that you had that before
you yeah what do you [ __ ] what do you
think you get from it just that it's fun
that it's exciting to have sex you like
to have sex yeah I do
it doesn't hurt I love to suck dick oh
my foots right let me not get too
explicit as explicit as you like here oh
yeah okay you tell me anything you want
okay I like that
what's the kinkiest craziest thing you
had a customer um you mentioned
something with this gentleman oh yeah
yeah he's the only person I let [ __ ]
my but I just started that as anything
well we on the Internet right I may have
to pay you extra for that one okay I'll
take that I guess will you consider
yourself more of an escort or prostitute
escort that's correct okay well there
you go and you're in escrow
thank you yeah so you've moved up yeah I
started up I moved on actually what
really yeah oh I see I never walked the
street before and before that I danced
was a huge river yeah
and how does this compare to way more
money this is more money
let's work I might be getting fat now
what does dancing keeps you really good
and shaved you know yeah [ __ ] yeah
I'm about to put a pole in where I'm
staying I'm about to play I wouldn't put
a polling for me just so I'm just right
yes just so I can play on it yep yeah I
can do some badass tricks all right
princess thank you so much for talking
thank you thank you
you